and the right-hander cinzatella
getting the start for the rockies who by
the way have won 15
of their last 19 at home this team i
mean it really is a
tale of two teams because they have been
good at home senzatella
has been solid for this ball club as
well went five
innings last time out of look at the
hyundai pitch arsenal here for antonio
cenzantella
really it's two pitches he's gonna use
his four-seam fastball
he'll elevate that thing use it up in
the zone and then tries to get swinging
misses with the slider
that he uses down the way to right he's
down and in to the left he's has a curve
has a change up that'll mix in there as
well but mainly that four
seam fastball on the slider
and a swing and a miss on a 97 mile an
hour fastball
so a nice start for senzutel as he fans
dylan carlson
should be his 300th career appearance at
coors field and that's a base hit into
right
and now the crowd many of them rising to
their feet
as they should to salute nolan aronado
i would say that was a prolonged mostly
ovation and fittingly so for nolan
and nolan pops it up on the infield
krone is going to handle it two outs
hard shot to short handled nicely by
story
and well done by senzatella he gets
nolan
he gave up a hit to goldschmidt nothing
else across
middle of what adam wainwright is on the
mound for the cardinals a record of six
and five ground ball percentage around
50
you like to see that even higher if you
can do that at coors field yeah
you will and you really have to
concentrate on getting the ball down
there the hyundai pitch arsenal for adam
wainwright you know he's going to use
that two seam that sinker that you
mentioned there dan to get some of those
ground balls to cut her really effective
in on the lefties and old uncle charlie
uses it about 35 percent of the time
we know that thing's good and it has
historically still been
good at coors field the numbers for adam
wainwright have been solid there
he's a veteran guy he makes adjustments
quickly
1-2 on hampshire
there's the curveball swatted to left
for a base hit
the garrett hanson and the ball gets
away for a moment there's no uncovered
second because tommy edmond had to go
fetch the baseball and garrett says i'll
take advantage of that
it's going to be an error on tyler
o'neill 2-2 pitch
he struck him out
tommy hits it the other way the gap into
left center
that ball is down and tommy can fly on
his way to second
he'll try for third on his way in there
save it's a triple tommy edmond
i think this is a key at bat for paul de
young you have to find a way to get this
run home
see what he does in the hitters count
and a young
base hit that'll score tommy edmond
it sneaks past mcmahon and story
and de young gets the hit and the
cardinals go on top it's one
nothing here's brendan rodgers
dead center his fifth of the year and
the rockies are in front two to one
paul goldschmidt at the plate as goldie
hits one
a ton deep left at the wall
gone and he's tied it up at 2-2
solo shots don't kill you reaching
for it there's arnado and he makes the
play
one two three go the rockies coming up
to young bader and wayne oh
two to our score his 43rd gear
yeah he's got 714 at bats
he's not getting a hit this time
breaking ball strikes about one
two three in the fourth for senza
a couple more strikeouts got four inside
with the fastball
he smokes it to left
and that's where wayne wright wanted to
put that pitch because he's shook to all
of those pitches
[Applause]
goldie the catch and it's a double play
a line drive and back up
and doubles up rogers at third the
rockies combination at third 16 home
runs 51 rbis swung on the midst on an
off speed pitch
and sensatella fans know it and works a
one two three fifth he's retired eight
in a row
we're tied at two
[Applause]
and the 1-0 grounded to short clubbed by
de young
one two three go the rockies and we head
to the sixth then
sometimes you you're battling my
strength against third string
this time it works in your favor
ground ball nice pickup by mcmahon
another strong inning
for antonio senzatella
middle of six took only 10 pitches 2-2
that's all you need to do slow it down a
little bit
another fly ball out to deep left and
backing up on the edge of the track
tyler o'neill an eight pitch hit back
the young vader wano coming up
as we head to inning number seven
ground ball to first cj retreats fields
it
runs to the bag and senzatella has
safely navigated the seventh inning will
stretch at coors field
rockies two cardinals two 3-2 pitch
back to adam wainwright out there to
first
double play
a huge double play started by old uncle
charlie
the effort that he put in each and every
day
tyler o'neil high fly ball deep left
center field it's got some carry to it
at the wall it's caught
it does not matter nice hitting daniel
ball
he walked edmond but he strikes out the
young
and bader will go to the bottom of the
ninth inning now the winning rod
in conventional scoring position for a
guy who all of a sudden is swinging it
really well jeff houston and elias diaz
drive
[Applause]
continues